and welcome to Hannity and tonight it is
official the most arrogant dishonest
press secretary in modern American
history she will soon be gone in a
little over a week Chief propaganda
Circle back Jen saki will step down
after reportedly negotiating a big new
contract with NBC News the former home
of lying Brian anyway I'm sure saki will
feel right at home at the conspiracy
Channel network and coming up we're
going to give her a proper and very
special send-off Jen I hope he'll Circle
back with us and watch later also
tonight a disturbing story out of Los
Angeles the city's far left district
attorney is now refusing to pursue
felony charges for the man that
viciously assaulted comedian I like Dave
Chappelle a lot he's funny as hell
anyway but he attacked him while
wielding a gun-shaped knife a fake gun a
real knife a gun that looked like a
knife we'll show you that in moments and
like many liberal cities La happily
there you can see hap happily tolerates
violent crime no bail laws oh let's see
defund dismantle the police oh Kamala
Harris praised the LAPD for this
defunding some of the LAPD more Straight
Ahead first we do turn to the steps of
the U.S Supreme Court now surrounded by
a large chain-link fence with big cement
barriers erected overnight to protect
the building rightly so in my opinion we
need to protect every institution every
monument every person that serves in
this government this is the right thing
to do hopefully Democrats have learned
something from the 574 riots in the
summer of 2020 and the capital breach in
2021 by the way still no answers as to
why Nancy Pelosi and mayor Muriel Bowser
didn't use the up to 20 000 troops
authorized required by law by Donald
Trump two days prior again is required
by law why didn't they uh now many
people on the left are very very angry
angry that individual states and voters
could soon decide abortion law for their
state overturning Roe v Wade all the
Talking Points all the lying all the
hysteria it's not true it will not
Outlaw abortion in the United States
that is the big lie that is being spread
by the likes of vote Chuck Schumer who
himself threatened two justices Justice
Gorsuch and Kavanaugh on the steps of
the U.S Supreme Court screaming you
won't know what hit you among other
threats and as we speak they're
threatening to burn our system to the
ground as per usual Democrats are
turning to their favorite political
tactic that's mob violence and
intimidation one liberal group is now
organizing an effort to stalk and harass
Supreme Court Justices and their
families at their homes uh this is not
okay in this country but tonight
prominent Democrats they refuse to
condemn this threatening behavior just
like they refuse to ever speak out
against the violence from their base in
the 574 riots in the summer of 2020.
take a look
so he doesn't care if they're protesting
outside the Supreme Court or outside
someone's private
I don't have an official U.S government
position on where people protest the
reason people are protesting is because
women across the country are worried
about their fundamental rights that have
been law for 50 years their rights to
make choices about their own bodies and
their own health care are at risk that's
why people are protesting they're
unhappy they're scared
the message here give us what we are
want or else is that the message Adam
Schiff he also also demonized the
justices and called for court packing by
the way Senator Mike Lee Utah has a new
book coming out on this very topic now
clearly the marching orders have been
given uh is does this mean now what the
summer of 2020 and all the riots does
that mean that season is back I pray to
God no my prediction is this if God
forbid something does happen like the
summer of 2020
574 riots in America we had dozens dead
thousands of cops injured and tens of
billion dollars of property damage and
guess what nobody investigated anything
and the left defended it they were
silent when they needed to speak out
their silence was deafening they only
condemned violence and riots that
obviously Advance their own political
narrative on this show I have and I will
continue to condemn all violence
politics should not play a part in that
we should protect our institutions our
elected officials that's a simple slam
dunk for me just like in 2020 during the
BLM riots that left dozens dead
thousands injured all of this happened
how is it that nobody covered this how
was it that many on the Democratic side
were so unwilling to condemn what was
obvious now fake news CNN referred to it
right that scene right there as a fiery
but peaceful demonstration they actually
said that it's the same year Senator
Rand Paul you might remember and his
wife were nearly trampled by far left
protesters after the RNC convention
left-wing rioters also showed up as
Senator Mitch McConnell's home
confronted him and his wife they also
harassed the pair at a local Diner I'm
sure you remember that moment they also
terrorized Senator Josh hawley's wife
and their newborn baby at their front
door they confronted Ted Cruz and his
wife at a restaurant they also harassed
Trump's DHS secretary at a restaurant we
played that tape before because they
didn't like Trump's border wall in 2018
they stormed the steps of the U.S
Supreme Court they pounded on the front
door in order to disrupt Kavanaugh's
confirmation and more recently they
followed Senator Christian Cinema into a
bathroom and filmed her going into a
stall because she wouldn't kill the
filibuster now they later then also took
their kayaks out and they went over to
Joe manchin's houseboat because he
wouldn't support build-back broke
America and while this far left brand of
political intimidation rarely Works
Democrats just they just can't seem to
help themselves but don't worry they'll
never be an investigation into this take
a look
you cannot be civil with a political
party that wants to destroy what you
stand for what you care about but I like
to debate this gentleman and I said no I
said if we're in high school I'd take
him behind the gym and beat the hell out
of them you got to be ready to take a
punch
you got to be ready to throw a punch
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
on both levels that this isn't they're
not going to let up and they should not
I want to tell you more such I want to
tell you Kavanaugh you have released the
Whirlwind and you and you will pay the
price get up in the face of some
Congress people it does you any good
running away from Donald Trump I think
you need to go back and punch him in the
face I'll dare he say the things he does
of course I want to punch him in the
face
yes
I have thought an awful lot about
blowing up the White House when was the
last time an actor assassinated a
president
[Applause]
she always says that you know when they
go low we go out no no they go low we
kick
my favorite was Barack Obama telling
this guy Mr Burgess we'll put Mr Burgess
up again Sean Hannity he'll eat him up
uh I'm ready anyway Democrats love mob
rule but only when they're on the losing
side of an issue now they are six months
away from what could be an election beat
down it's no secret the American people
are not happy rightly so inflation
historically bad gas prices historically
bad the Border worse than ever the
supply chain crisis is totally messed up
no one on the world stage or even in
this country seems likes Joe Biden or
respects him and now a massive drop
today in the stock market could spell
the beginning of a painful new recession
as president Trump very accurately
predicted Joe Biden is destroying this
great American economy and he's doing it
in record time sadly
let me tell you about the stock market
when the stock market goes up that means
jobs it also means 401ks if you got in
if you ever became president with your
ideas you want to terminate my tax my
taxes I'll tell you what you'll lose
half of the companies that have poured
in here will leave and plenty of
companies that are already here they'll
lead to other places have they will
leave and you will have a depression the
likes of which you've never seen
oh looks like Trump was right again
anyone else missed slow gas prices
record low unemployment and major
economic growth because that's what we
got with President Trump I'll choose
that guy that guy that calls out fake
news for what they are fake and makes
occasional mean tweets but gets the job
done I choose him anyway now under Biden
we get economic turmoil along with a
cognitive mess as a President Who blames
all of his problems on Trump supporters
or Vladimir Putin yesterday he called us
the most extreme political faction in
modern American history actually in
American history in response today
former president Trump he reacted he
told Fox news.com quote our country is
going to hell the make America great
again movement is saving America my
message to Joe is there is nothing
extreme about energy Independence in a
secure border there's nothing extreme
about safe cities in the rule of law
there's nothing extreme about parental
involvement in the a children's
education there's nothing extreme about
freedom of speech and freedom of
expression there's nothing extreme about
individual states regulating abortion
and sadly there is an extreme political
faction in this country but there on the
other side of the fence outside the
Supreme Court and inside the walls of
1600 Pennsylvania Avenue the most
radical government ever elected in the
modern era by far it's not even close
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else